no
o no
o
yo sé que hay alguien en el auditorio
que de pronto me entendía
bueno resulta que les voy a contar en la
clase de hoy una historia y todo surgió
precisamente porque no sabía lengua de
señas colombiana y quiero aprovechar el
momento para preguntarles si ustedes en
el auditorio presente conocen o han
estudiado lengua de señas colombiana o
por ejemplo el braille como código
lingüístico para las personas ciegas
levanten la mano
[Música]
imagínense que por eso comenzó esta
historia y resulta que todo surgió a
través de una semilla que se alimentó
tanto y creció tanto que se convirtió en
un árbol con muchos frutos y allí fue
donde yo empecé con el interés de
conocer esta lengua porque empezaron a
entrar a la universidad donde yo estudié
mi licenciatura en diseño estudiantes
sordos y yo no sabía cómo saludarlos
imagínense cómo me sentía yo tiene una
barrera comunicativa imagínense cómo se
sienten ellos que no saben ni siquiera
leer escribir en algunos casos o
escucharme si no me podían escuchar cómo
me comunicaba entonces para mí fue una
una mayor interés empezar a acercarme a
conocer esta lengua y a estudiarla y aún
todavía después de todos estos años
todavía sigo estudiando porque creo que
nunca voy a terminar de aprender lo rica
que es esta lengua
a partir de allí resulta que todos
sabemos que cuando llegamos a la
universidad ya finalizando la carrera
llega a la tesis
y en la tesis entonces qué vamos a hacer
de proyecto de grado y allí fue donde
conocí a mi asesor de tesis que ahora es
mi amigo y que le debo mucho lo que me
dijo en ese momento él me dijo no hagas
un proyecto por graduarte o un trabajo
por presentar sino un proyecto de vida
yo en ese momento de pronto no entendí
mucho pero ahora lo comprendo muchísimo
mejor porque resulta que se convirtió en
mi proyecto de vida
a partir de allí entonces yo dije ya sé
que voy a hacer de tesis voy a empezar a
apoyar y a potenciar la comunicación con
esa comunidad sorda que era una de mis
mayores falencias entonces se investigue
e investigue y me di cuenta que en
colombia tenemos una cantidad de
personas con discapacidad impresionante
y que tienen barreras no solo
comunicativas sino de enseñanza
aprendizaje y acceso a la educación y
acceso al trabajo entonces imagínense
que me inventé
una herramienta
y en esa herramienta que investigue y
consulte
cree un software que permitirá reconocer
la voz y la traducida lengua de señas
colombiana para empezar a aprender y
enseñar la lengua de señas colombiana y
a partir de allí empezó a cambiar y
revolucionar mi vida porque empecé a
crear muchos más proyectos y no y no se
vayan a aburrir porque son muchos y
todavía no me detengo porque son muchos
proyectos y muchas estrategias que
precisamente he podido potenciar a
través de el uso de la tecnología allí
fue donde efectivamente creé este
proyecto y me dio la oportunidad a la
universidad de continuar estudiando mis
estudios de maestría me dedicaron con la
maestría y pude desarrollar y continuar
aplicando toda esta tecnología para
ayudar a las personas sin embargo ahí
todavía yo no lo había comprendido muy
bien había desarrollado el proyecto lo
había aplicado con excompañeros sordos
pero hasta ahí llegué
luego de eso cuando ya empecé a hacer la
maestría imagínense que me inventé otro
proyecto surgió otra idea y allí creé un
software que permitía reconocer las
señales del cerebro para traducirlos al
lenguaje verbal y escrito ya estaba
integrando a la comunidad sorda para que
ellos empezaron a comunicarse conmigo
entonces les estaba enseñando lengua de
señas amigos colegas oyentes tradicional
estábamos aprendiendo también de ellos
ellos nos estaban comunicando entonces
digamos que se fue como el inicio de
muchas cosas sin embargo yo no me podía
quedar estudiando toda la vida tenía que
trabajar y empecé a trabajar como
profesora en un colegio y allí fue donde
realmente le vi uno de los mayores
enfoques al proyecto y fue que pude
encontrar a un niño que tenía sordera
estaba quedándose sordo a pesar del
tiempo y su familia no sabía era sordo
congénito entonces se acuerdo en este
proyecto que hice en mi licenciatura
pues lo pude aplicar pero con este niño
y le empecé a enseñar lengua de señas y
allí fue donde realmente había aplicado
mi proyecto y dije escogí la carrera que
era porque mi carrera se basa en crear
desarrollos tecnológicos para solucionar
problemas y estaba solucionando un
problema una necesidad entonces allí en
ese proceso en conocí a mis estudiantes
y empecé a desarrollar todas esas
estrategias y me dieron una luz en el
camino mis niños en el colegio porque
resulta que no solo me podía quedar con
la comunidad sorda y como ustedes
observan la mayoría lo había
desarrollado para mis compañeros sordos
y resulta que en mi colegio me encontré
que tenemos actualmente 64 niños con
discapacidad en básica primaria y
contando los de bachillerato tenemos 99
estudiantes con discapacidad en
diferentes aspectos que hice entonces
empezar a enamorar a mis niños de décimo
y once para que ellos empezaron a crear
tecnología inclusiva y empezamos a
apadrinar niños de primaria ya encontrar
sus necesidades identificarlas y empezar
a crear soluciones tecnológicas
imagínense ustedes estudiantes de décimo
y once creando tecnología inclusivo y
apadrinando a un niño con discapacidad
y resulta que allí me dieron la
oportunidad de vincularme a trabajar en
una universidad y se acuerdan esos dos
proyectos que hice en la licenciatura en
la maestría pues resulta que pude crear
las mismas versiones y la mayoría
tenemos dispositivos móviles y podemos
acceder a un celular entonces lo mismo
que ha hecho en el software lo hice en
las aplicaciones y creamos con mis
estudiantes de la universidad tres
aplicaciones móviles que permiten
integrar el lenguaje verbal y la lengua
de señas colombiana ustedes sabían que
los sordos su lengua materna la lengua
de señas colombiana y en el momento en
el que aprenden una segunda lengua se
convierten en sordos bilingües en este
caso el español leído y escrito esa
segunda lengua entonces allí fue donde
precisamente potencie todo este
desarrollo después de eso llegó mi
tercer mejor proyecto mi pequeño hijo y
luego de eso como no me gusta quedarme
quieta
llegó otra idea dije tengo mi formación
en tecnología que me hace falta mi
formación en inclusión y busque un
doctorado en educación inclusiva en
muchas partes del mundo y lo encontré y
el año pasado terminé mi doctorado en
educación inclusiva y poder continuar
potenciando todos estos proyectos y
surgió una alternativa mucho más
interesante imagínense que el ministerio
de educación nacional de colombia hace
una convocatoria para que 18 profesores
de colombia puedan viajar a corea del
sur cada año a potenciar el uso de las
herramientas tecnológicas
yo me presenté durante tres años
seguidos el año pasado para sí así que
no me voy incluso pensé en desfallecer
pero mi familia me apoyó y mis
compañeros de trabajo para que yo no
desfallecerá y entonces efectivamente lo
logré y no se imaginan la emoción de
cumplir este sueño de ir a korea así
como le dijeron que me gustan el anime y
el manga estaba un poquito más cerca
aparte y me fui con una maleta llegué
con tres no sólo llena de recursos
tecnológicos sino de sueños y metas para
transmitir a mis compañeros ya mis
estudiantes ya potenciar todo ese
trabajo y se imagina que yo pensé que lo
de korea iba hasta allí pero no fácil
imagínense que llegando de korea en
octubre del año pasado los coreanos
visitan colombia y me escogen dentro de
cuatro profesores de colombia para
visitar colegios ustedes se imaginan la
visita de esos coreanos en mi colegio
mandamos a hacer ajiaco almojábanas con
agua panela y queso y lo recibimos de la
mejor manera como ellos me hicieron
sentir como en casa así que yo hice lo
posible para que se sintieran de la
mejor manera en mi colegio y mi rector
mis compañeros y mis estudiantes se
movilizaron para recibir a esta
comunidad que es una potencia a nivel
educativo y tecnológico que nos está
enseñando algo y efectivamente allí
aprendí con esos 18 profesores de
colombia a que puedo aportar fortalecer
y potenciar estos desarrollos y esta
alternativa de solución entonces como
hago yo para crear todos estos proyectos
y todas estas alternativas y adicional a
ello que lo más importante es dejar
huella a mis estudiantes
algo que no quiero irme sin contarles es
que una de mis estudiantes en esa visita
de korea era de las mejores creó una
herramienta que permitía una persona con
amputación de miembro superior poder
controlar un computador con su cabeza
imagínense que de korea le ofrecieron
una beca para irse a estudiar este año
está estudiando inglés para que el otro
año se puede ir a estudiar entonces
efectivamente qué hacemos nosotros desde
la universidad y desde el colegio
identificamos una problemática una
necesidad de una persona con
discapacidad
luego planteamos alternativas de
solución después identificamos una
posible solución teniendo en cuenta las
personas el equipo mató y tecnológico
necesario para poder desarrollar esa
estrategia y luego aprobar esta
propuesta ese es el proceso que nosotros
desarrollamos para crear semillas
inclusivas para crear semilleros de
investigación escolar y universitario
que potencien y ayuden a las personas
con discapacidad que tienen tantas
necesidades
y en este o en este sentido precisamente
cuál es mi meta y cuál es el objetivo
para que realmente colombia sea
inclusiva tenemos que empezar por que yo
sea inclusivo
una familia inclusiva un colegio
inclusivo una universidad inclusiva y un
país inclusivo una ciudad inclusiva y si
llegara una colombia inclusiva y
probablemente el mundo inclusivo y
aquino para todo hay muchas cosas y
muchas metas y espero seguir continuando
compartiendo con ustedes todas estas
estrategias y alternativas de solución
que lo que realmente hacen es que se
potencian los proyectos pero yo no estoy
sola en todos estos proyectos tengo a mi
familia mis amigos mis colegas docentes
mis jefes mi equipo de trabajo mis nueve
compañeros tx que me han apoyado y que
han sembrado en mí muchas semillas así
que quiero hacerles una pregunta para
continuar y por seguir potenciando todo
mi trabajo de inclusión hoy he logrado
sembrar en ustedes en sus corazones
semillas inclusivas
entonces los invito a que la próxima
clase nos veamos pero para aprender y
potenciar el uso de la lengua de señas
el braille y la tecnología inclusiva
para ayudar a todas estas personas con
discapacidad y que colombia sea
realmente un país inclusivo
y
[Música]
no
y